pas ressasser ces lots les râles
pourrait alors le libéralisme selon est
bien là raymond aron le centre de ma
pensée est différent je considère que
les sociétés démocratiques et
industriels dans lesquels nous vivons
sont toujours un degré ou un autre
gaieté ou menacés par les formes
totalitaire et qu'en particulier les
grands ensembles risque de détruire les
possibilités de l'individu alors ce
qu'on appelle mans libéralisme c'est la
défense des institutions représentatives
de la pluralité des partis et d'autre
part l'effort doit l'organisation
économique et sociale de sauvegarder les
chances de l'individu et les libertés
fondamentales
merci à tous les deux alors quelques
jours